[Music]
turn down your speakers now
welcome to the y i'm very excited holy
cow
93 000 upvotes that's got to be one of
the all-time highest ones okay maybe not
youtuber consistently take a photo every
day for 10 years
how long is this
oh there it is there's the shaved head
big oh god i became uglier
oh no
happy 10 years anniversary pizza oh my
god that's so nice the prabhata
that is amazing thank you so much for
doing that that was the take in
so long god i love that i don't know why
this is interesting to see all the
development his hair and his beard look
like they're having a turf war all right
let's see what else we got i freaking
love becky so much
becky being a becky here who the hell is
becky our pewdiepie and felix schelberg
the same person or twins twins might
once a gamer wants a comedian oh
i don't really know who they are
now felix was in lasagna pewdiepie was
in scare pity by what the hell this is
so confusing i've not seen either of
them that's pewdiepie that's felix oh my
god they look so similar
see why people get confused yeah man
weirdest wow that's so weird
unbelievable this even confused me what
the hell
don't blame becky i have a twin what
wait until she sees gloria porker and
poppy harlow her mind will be blown they
look exactly the same
you're approaching me
amazing fanart ricardo
see i said in my last video you only
work out to escape time and death but i
was wrong you work out so ricardo won't
steal your wife i'm coming for you
ricardo bring it bring your a game
ninjas then your wish is my command
sensei ninjas now i'm not seeing it
i love this meme and i'm definitely
gonna kill it in the next meme review
it's so funny it's basically beta and
chad rebranded but it's got some all
right i'll save it for meme review felix
skelberg pewdiepie
see i get this now because we're
watching phineas and ferb that's right
every live stream we watch one episode
of fitness and firebase it's been really
fun actually so i get it i understand
i'm one of you guys and you better not
complain now and be like oh it's not
funny anymore because pewdiepie knows it
become a member guys you get access to
all the offline live streams if you want
to watch it don't cry babe it's just a
movie don't cry babe it's just a 30 year
old man who stops playing minecraft
minecraft dungeons baby i play it on the
live streams again i don't mean to shill
for my membership live streams but all
the footage access through membership if
you want just to clarify these two are
the same person both absolute chads look
at them i should probably shave pretty
soon it's probably time to let it go my
head look at that bald head that's
beautiful
beautiful thank you all right we got a
fan art
let go
dope i don't know if i ever wanted to
see myself as garfield but i'm okay i'm
okay with it really cool fine art upload
very nice did i just say upvote oh
cringe big peepee oh yes yeah
oh duh they're trying to influence me
[Laughter]
boy with broken tambourine is an actual
sculpture this is so sad guys i would
show my tambourine but it's undergoing
surgery right now it's been a 24 hour
process it's very delicate it's very
difficult
i'm just praying every single day guys
pray for tambourine in the comments down
below he's gonna be okay
took 21 hours
and now i get to know that it's broken
that's so dope amazing firearm
look at this i saw my neck oh god
subscribe right now
neck 20 increase immediately linus makes
a custom
top of the line creeper pc for felix
felix quits minecraft
let this be like bruh hey can we talk
about linus chad linda's chat
transformation there it is
10 out of 10. now start lifting
immediately
2016 2020 2024 2030 all right all right
i'm getting a new camera guys i'll fix
this i think it's time
for me to fix my quality
i'm getting some hints here and there
i'm getting like this feedback from you
guys i noticed just a couple comments
about it and i think it might be time to
change
when enemy dudes is about to die and
then start having flashbacks of his
entire life the villain
i'll just be chilling meanwhile you go
ahead have a two episode flashback no
problem i'll just chill here homie damn
damn
i gotta show uh that's a key that's cute
that's amazing you guys are so talented
and i'm so glad i always look so good in
my fine art as well you see
pewdiepie fan art my cfn
oh actually i found a fan art i don't
think this is on the y but it's made by
enzo fernandez
art
i love it so much thank think see i get
the best stuff i don't know why i'm like
i get the best it's just cool that
people do it that's super dope
so cute
amazing fitness and verb episode two
lawn gnome there there it is that was a
great episode you did it you crazy son
of a
you did it it's a good show it's a
legitimately good show i drew pewdiepie
dragon fan art for pooch pewdiepie
dragon damn the textures are amazing
kind of want to like
you know what i mean you know what i
mean i want to put my pee pee okay my
mom look at shooting star make a wish it
will come true me done puppy gloria
she'll come back one day i actually uh
been waiting to confirm this but papa
gloria just like tambourine is
undergoing 24-hour surgery there is a
possible that she might not make it the
treadmill will hit her very hard but
pray for puppy gloria she might come
back how to change
a tambourine head
i need to look into this how is it done
this is the live footage of the 24 hour
surgery or you can use that rubber band
if you have two people
the uploader is running what's going on
in the comment section
[Laughter]
one picture a thousand words
behold
my husband six-pack behold everyone
great lightning is that what that is
lighting nothing else 2020 can't get any
worse 2020 bye bye minecraft bye bye
i'll still play it okay i will never
stop playing minecraft
that's a lie i i just feel like i can't
do them weekly if they don't update the
game but i'll probably make some i'll
make some more episodes stop crying
there it is
listen before people challenge me for
boxing match i say no i'm tired homie
i'm just chilling now
bring it i'm ready anyone i challenge
everyone in the world
oh
that is so cute
huge peepee ginormous oh my god it
continues
it carries so good
i love spend the most of it
okay we got ulabita
oh my god stefano sleepy sweater cat why
does all my pet die
no
hey maya nedgar still alive no problem
guys this year can't get any worse oh
god
[Music]
mr beast let's start a gaming channel
and play minecraft pewdiepie bye bye
minecraft mr beast this is so sad mr
beast is shaking and crying twitch
streamers you guys need to donate felix
stop donating is is sometimes people
donate to me and be like this is the
last bit of money i'm like don't do it
what are you doing stop simply for me
all right you're doing it wrong look at
the size of those legs so here we have a
photo uh unedited so this might be a
good reference point so ikea tower is
roughly
600 one kilometer tall
i'm half the length so i should be
around
10 000 meters tall something like that
that's just an estimate rough estimate
could be anywhere between 10 000 meters
and zero okay we have the rock
wait is that
one punch man before he oh really i
didn't know that there it is
there it is
thanks for all the support on my workout
review video that was really nice i'm
glad you guys enjoy that you can't
recognize somebody just from their torso
there it is
when you're a girl and get rated big pp
you're welcome everyone you're welcome
girls hey i don't discriminate on this
channel all right out all exclusive
exclusive that's right inclusive women
can have big peepee too i said it
multiple times marzia fan art felix
ferdart wow thank you guys so much for
this fan art how many hours it takes oh
here it is okay pewdiepie now i am
married man and i've got ripped app
ripped abs rip tabs pewdiepie then oh no
barrel so scared
big beep
maybe laugh very nice goodbye my friends
quick fan art oh
it's a good fan art big pippy
is that paint which one is paint
deal oh i like that cyber is my stand
that's pretty cool actually that's a
cool idea that's the real reason to work
out so you can look like a jojo
character so many people when they saw
that photo they're like
he watched jojo i understand even though
it is a bit silly to have a goal even if
it's like not even possible because no
one's more buff than to you it doesn't
hurt to have a an image of a goal i'm
not gay but damn
sam
sand
he was like father to me
tempore inside he's in surgery pray for
tambourine
when the tambourine finally breaks
marcel was devastated
i'll let you know i'll have you know
martin was not happy teacher today we're
going to talk about how glass is made me
after 500 plus hours of minecraft which
i already know pierce kills a sheep
everyone else hey i've seen this one no
you haven't no you haven't stop lying
he's not gray and he needs to be a grey
sheep that's not water sheep i won
but that would cost
a deep cost here's me shelling for new
uh two bird content the new update it's
cool check it out game is still fun not
gonna lie felix bye bye minecraft
minecraft dungeons you guys call
what is with my voice i recorded i
recorded yesterday singing that's that's
why okay i have always oh
this is my voice this is my real voice
this is a voice reveal uh
hey guys it's me big time tommy we need
koreans in their 30s playing minecraft
[Laughter]
goodbye
big pp
link's email it's okay i have another
one licks it i did it
join livestream for me making more royal
[ __ ] ups but good times good times are
had
damn
oh
i'm not gay but damn
i gained over bro
you should give people a copy of your
worlds and see what they do with it
okay i like that idea i like that idea a
lot it's fairly big though where can i
upload it like a big file for many
people to download it
come join us tambourine no not yet
no he's alive he's fine pray for
tambourine one like equals one prayer
anime netflix adaptation
i was just trying to get that's a tough
part to get over it's a rough one before
joe here it is before jojo
after jojo goal after jojo go
felix upload a video while live
streaming me an intellectual there it is
the subreddit when felix made sven and
deep have alabama the subreddit when
phillips made a literal sex chamber for
some villagers in which generations
were repeated so that he could have
slaves who would give him anything
but no now you've crossed the line felix
you made the dogs go peepee inside
i'm not playing mine if terraria yet i
am the worst
oh god i'm sorry actually i should write
it down so i don't forget it i keep
forgetting play terraria you [ __ ] now
now i won't forget it
there it is
i thought it was the karen haircut first
it confused me
are you waiting felix
no
next year i'll win the tambourine
challenge oh wait yeah sure we'll call
it that from now on the smell of vanilla
extract the taste of vanilla extract so
true this is so true
should i make one more video on
whatever his name is i'm kind of curious
what happened afterwards no one 15 year
olds in anime yes
finally i've reached the body of a 15
year old
oh no
it's true though i'm always so pissed
off by it they practice for like a week
and then they're like
muscles muscles now roses are red pewds
amps have been seen but all pay respect
for his dead tambourine
he's not dead he just got hit by a
treadmill it's not his fault use code
pewdiepie for discount that's right i
didn't talk about this in my video i
didn't want to get too much in diets but
yes i only eat g fuel that's my whole
entire diet nothing else before g fuel
after g fuel very nice
hey felix do you dream in swedish or
english
people keep asking this i i think it's
very contextualized
a big word okay epic for example if i
notice if i write a note i always write
in english but if i'm writing a note
related to
sweden or something regarding my parents
uh it just naturally it switches to
swedish and i think it's the same with
their dreaming if i mean somewhere in
sweden in a dream i dream in swedish and
yeah that's just how it is
alabama lord of netherrealm
please accept these melons please bless
my safe travels across your land sir
amazing resting peace temporary
i told jack he should sacrifice his bell
to resurrect tambourine but he refused
can you believe this mojang studios new
name logo and trailer so long old
partner so long i don't like the red but
i i like the font that they picked i
think it looks better hospital gang ow
confused noises
thank you for the sacrifice to protect
the recovery you clear the disturbance
off oh dog
very nice
yeah oh my god
i forgot to that was like here sorry
just edit this i don't even think about
it he has to watch all these awful sh
i'm the worst i'm sorry simon thank you
for editing that video
i just realized simon had to blur the
footage and saw all the awful stuff i'm
sorry sorry
i didn't even prep him i'm sorry
oh god hey sweden 17th century hippity
hoppity your land is now my property now
don't hit me i'm swedish please oh no
no
oh now we change so we the good now oh
we take back finland oh we take back
norway oh denmark i don't really want it
you can go you're free to go anime
characters at the start of training
montage anime characters at the end
there it is i just need a real sensei
then we'll see some real progress how to
change a tambourine head someone get
this man in a boat
felix saying bye twos pets in minecraft
alabama
did i not say bye to alabama no
google has removed eight million reviews
from tick tock
what the hell
pewds minecraft
chance
terraria this is so sad i'll probably
live stream terraria but i'll still
upload it as a video on its own because
it's been so long that i played and i
feel like i need some help oh
dude
you're challenging me you're approaching
me ricardo you're approaching me you
protect the attack but most importantly
he will be there waiting for you when
you get back
when your friend were sponsored by
mojang that's dope i'm proud of them
that's really cool no
[Laughter]
it's evolving just backwards
what comes to my brain when pewd says
huge pp
oh wow
joint floor gang 20 pp increase
instantly female or male it will happen
look at those curls incredible
the pp is strong with this one the pp is
strong with this one
jack and felix doing the 50 50.
god damn it start the minecraft series
unmarried nine year olds did not have
100 million subs chair gang cringe and
the minecraft stairs married to merch 19
year olds reach 100 ml floor gang ow
20 muscle increase are we not going to
add that the smell of vanilla extract
the taste of vanilla extract extract yes
i said that right thank you felix
accidentally breaks his tambourine
that's 19 year olds
this is so sad dear felix now that you
have seen fitness and fur properly how
do you feel about these pictures
why
i get it though haha i can laugh at this
haha i get it god damn it
just when this was getting wholesome it
just ended just want to thank pewdiepie
for helping me at my lowest lows oh i
hope you recover soon there's no need to
thank me hope you do better soon yeah
that's right felix 2025 oh no no felix
2021 baby let's get it all right guys
thank you so much for all the memes fan
art and all the lives appreciate it it's
really fun remember to become a member
and i see you guys tomorrow i think i'm
not sure i might take a day off actually
okay see you guys brofist
[Music]
hey